it's that time again I guess I gotta
make another video let's see how the
comments did on my last one why am I
talking smoothly ran out of ideas
Loki running out of ideas out of that
when you run a bike when your god damn
you're so [ __ ] you think I'm out of
ideas
boy
think I have this out you think I had
this soundboard because I'm out of
creative comedy ideas listen here listen
here okay
it was a joke okay I did it as a joke
once and now everyone's like he's out of
[ __ ] ideas he made a video he's out
of ideas I got stacks and stacks upon
ideas in my idea Bank haha okay so what
maybe I am out of ideas huh
but there's a good reason to it and when
you find out boy you're gonna wish you
never commented he's out of ideas ever
again because the truth might shock you
let's play something serious
overuse me I've been running an idea
business yes that's right for other
youtubers
I have have I've have so many ideas that
I've been exporting them basically I'm
the guy on top of YouTube and I've been
giving everyone else the best freshest
ideas because I care about YouTube and I
care about how it's going for everyone
it's true
I know it's Chucky and I'll prove it to
you okay I'm just gonna sit I'm just
gonna set open for business on my phone
and soon a bunch of youtubers is gonna
call asking for ideas Arlo Oh Oh Jax
films you need ideas okay I got it okay
I got it
calm down just read other people's
comments yes yes that's right
for 300 episodes but you already done
that 331 of I am out of ideas huh I am
out of ideas huh
it's the saltiest video ever what
how about 112 episodes of the same
goddamn thing oh oh you did that all as
well say marker play I got you fam don't
you worry you got a sexy voice just just
[ __ ] grunt just make some grunting
noises make it a fourth for Sears let's
play the fourteen-year-old girls will
love it and a 27 year old straight men
that's right love you too back
[Music]
have you opened your rice yeah yes
that's right it all makes sense
Oh another car hello who is this Smosh
oh that's okay
just make hundred and eighty five
episodes of eating food but I am out of
ideas apparently and while you're at it
make the same videos you've been making
since 1984 but it's not just youtubers
it's BuzzFeed as well when I was working
there I gave them all of my best ideas
American price we just can't afford time
for my idea this is my idea that's my
idea
it's also my idea that's definitely my
idea Hey eggs ility ha ha my man what's
up okay just I got I got you fam just
spin a fidgets spinner for 24 hours I
[Music]
know it's it's hilarious original least
bit Jimmy my man just spending fidget
spinning for 24 hours that's great okay
why are we still here mr. B's my boy
what is up spin the fidget spinner for
24 hours straight yes no one's ever done
it it's a creative original idea
[ __ ] I'm good damn I'm good at this
come on can you guys please just hit
subscribe cuz I could break my record if
you guys subscribe that would be so
awesome
[Music]
jacksepticeye what she won't girl all
you want to celebrate your run three
special just just make ten things you
don't know about me
number one you have a foot so good at
this I'm so good I've ideas dantdm what
is up my black brother and sorry I'm
sorry it was a joke it wasn't you
goddamnit
okay just make a fidget spin or video
[Music]
what is good you're homeless now that's
right no it's not a publicity stunt at
all get this but you'll make a video
you'll say that you're homeless you'll
dress up like you're a meatball and then
you say you gave out all gave away all
your [ __ ] but really you didn't because
no one's gonna check that [ __ ] anyway
Marissa who the [ __ ] are you Oh make a
video on how to shave your vagina
unfortunately you know the area itself
is so sensitive
oceaxe dinner you can do about it and I
feel like doing God's work thank you
face oh it's the whole face clan okay
alright listen up I got a great idea
hey I get it no one's watching your [ __ ]
anymore that's okay I can relate it's
okay don't panic it's gonna be okay it's
gonna you got a long life to live when
I'm sure all those money's gonna last so
don't you worry now what you gonna do
let's make a video on how you almost
died that's right that's right
twice you know what now don't think
about it make it three times three times
that's right yeah [ __ ] make it four
make it four you've almost died four
times how old are you twelve
you're welcome face apex you almost died
face cake you almost dad first birth you
almost done you all died okay face how
do they why haven't they done yet at
least one of them surely should have
been dead by now
hmm marks I didn't think you'd call I
got a great one I got a banger for you
my mom had sex with me when I was 12
that's right that's right wait a minute
you're not morgues you're a cancer cell
oh god damn it you tricked me you may
think I'm just [ __ ] around in this is
all just fake phone calls well I've got
testimonies of real youtubers who
approve of this service and if you're a
youtuber you can hire me as well because
I have so many great ideas just listen
to this fellow people millions of
creators suffer every year from taking
idea suggestions from PewDiePie I am one
of those creators I mean I knew his
ideas were bad but Jesus Christ it just
makes me wonder what planet is this guy
even from I don't get what could possess
someone to think of the ideas he thinks
of that may sound like a compliment but
it's not I feel like some of my worst
videos have come from passing
conversations with PewDiePie where he
said yeah that sounds cool he cursed the
idea the man is a curse PewDiePie wanted
me to come here today to tell you all
about the amazing ideas that he's given
me over the years but really he's given
me nothing but trauma just flat-out
doubting everything I've ever known type
of trauma
do not take advice from this man he is a
serial killer as in his ideas will kill
you and no in a good way so PewDiePie
[ __ ] you
PewDiePie is ideas legit almost killed
my channel I mean some of the worst
ideas ever came from him PewDiePie's
idea service has saved my ass on so many
occasions I can't even tell you how many
times I've relied on it just like [ __ ]
out another video God where would the
world be without his ideas / me
all of YouTube it kind of works out like
trickled down idea na mcc's where he
creates the ideas ending that he leases
it to his inner circle and then it flows
down and it trickles down all the way
through YouTube and everyone benefits
from it like not many people realize he
is the source of all the mediocre
watered-down ideas that you see I've
come out with some pretty awful videos
over the years and the worst of the
worst of the worst them have all been
ideas that PewDiePie is given to me
PewDiePie comes up to me one day online
he says to me hey Anthony like I really
love your reviews I really love your
channel but you know would be fun it'll
be really funny if you reviewed memes he
would co-host the channel with me and
Here I am like almost a year into doing
this meme series no sign from PewDiePie
all the videos are terrible and now my
whole YouTube career has really just
been shot in the leg over PewDiePie and
because this dude has essentially lied
to me about sort of collaborating on
this channel helping me with this
channel and you know the sort of getting
involved in this whole mean thing has
really just kind of sullied my
reputation to be quite honest sometimes
people say to me how would you come up
with all your ideas and the tupis I
don't whenever I'm out of ideas I just
messaged PewDiePie whenever I need help
he's always there he even gave me the
idea to dye my hair the same color as
his I just don't know where I'd be
without PewDiePie don't you feel
terrible now that you've all been
commenting he's out of ideas that's
right because I've had ideas I've just
been sharing the best ones for real
though I I've always really enjoyed with
youtubers trying out different things I
remember back in the day when all I did
was play amnesia
I really thought that's all my channel
was ever going to do or achieve I'm
really happy with the way my channel is
because it's so spread out you know one
day you can get a video with me yelling
some cancerous memes the other day I'm
talking about my favorite manga and I
really enjoy the mix of it and I it
makes it really satisfying and fun for
me
to do different things I'm really glad
I'm not locked into doing one thing but
it's see this whole mean with me running
out of ideas literally started because I
I guess I've tried out so many different
things but that's why I enjoy it enjoy
bye YouTube if I do different things
that doesn't mean like if I ran out of
ideas I'd be doing the same [ __ ] over
and over that's running out of ideas
trying out different things that is
[ __ ] hell I don't know what the [ __ ]
to say to place you I don't need to say
anything to please see you [ __ ] you and
as always
sister fist I dread the day that I don't
have PewDiePie's ideas to fuel my own
videos because without that constant
flow of mediocrity coming down the
waterfall that is YouTube and going down
to the bottom god we'd all be lost we'd
have to come up with our own sorry I
just thought of the fact that we'd have
to we'd have to come up with our own
ideas